soit la maladie on dit un schizophrène
non c'est on est atteint de
schizophrénie parce que chaque personne
est unique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faut savoir qu'une personne qui est
atteint de schizophrénie se fait plus de
mal à lui même qu aux autres pour moi ma
maladie en fait cédé à l'unicité des
hallucinations donc auditif visuel
je me voyais en fait faire du mal à des
personnes
[Musique]
chaque personne a sa schizophrénie donc
ma schizophrénie mois en fait ça se
montrait au début c'était tout le temps
se sentir en danger dans la rue
quelqu'un passe à côté de moi prêts à
limiter à se battre pour se protéger en
fait tout envoyer quelqu'un se passer
quand est qu'il est dangereux celui-là
après aussi c'est à la maison tout en
avant l'impression que tout ne regarde
on me parle toute insulte que à l'école
paraît tout on ne regarde tout môme
insultes et du coup c'est très dur
surtout parce que on a vraiment
l'impression de tourner contre qu'on est
tout seul
[Musique]
moi
mon traitement pour moi il m'aide en
fait parce qu'il va me permettre d'avoir
des moments où je n'ai plus les
hallucinations où je peux les mettre de
côté qu'en cas qui est dangereux tout
court ça va être quelqu'un qui n'est pas
soignée qui n'est pas stabilisé et voilà
moi pour moi quand on a trouvé le bon
médicament qu'on respecte les dos qu'on
respecte les soins à partir de ce moment
là on est bien faut savoir qu'une
personne qui est atteint de
schizophrénie se fait plus de mal à lui
même qu aux autres il y en a qui se
mutile il y en a qui kiffent quasiment
tous qui se mutile qui font les
tentatives de suicide moi je sais que ma
mère elle a trouvé des lettres que je me
souviens pas du tout les avoir écrits
c'était des lettres de suicide en fait
mais je les ai jamais fait mais voilà il
faut savoir qu'à un moment de ma vie
avant la clozapine maman et moi on avait
fait un pacte en fait c'est à dire si
jamais le traitement ne marchait pas je
ne voulais pas pu vivre parce que c'est
tellement dur que j'en pouvais plus
c'était c'était trop
[Musique]
souvent une personne ce qui devrait la
faire du mal à soi même
du coup le truc c'est quand on a un ami
ou cas qu'un convoi qui en détresse
parce que c'est la maladie la cie
ophrenie c'est une détresse
psychologique elle va faut pas la
laisser tomber faut vraiment lui donner
un coup de main le plus qu'on peut et je
pense que ce que les gens ils devraient
bien se mettre en tête c'est quelqu'un
psic en hôpital psychiatrique
c'est pas quelqu'un de tarés de
dangereux c'est kaka qui en détresse et
qui a besoin d aide